à bord tout
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
quatrième épisode du cycle débat 2.0
organisée par le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et l'innovation avec le soutien actif de
l'association un des sciences ce cycle
vous le savez il est organisé dans le
cadre de la fête de la science qui aura
lieu cette année du 6 au 14 octobre 2018
alors comment les réseaux sociaux
augmentent les actions et les
interactions de culture scientifique
technique et industrielle
comment mieux penser leur utilisation et
notamment au moment de la fête de la
science bien c'est tout l'objectif de
ces rendez vous que nous tournons en
direct tous les mercredis à 13h et
aujourd'hui eh bien j'ai le grand
plaisir et le privilège d'être en
compagnie de deux invités de marque ou
qu'est-ce que oui je suis en compagnie
de valentine de la traverse de confort
et de fred courant de l'esprit sur site
alors je dirais quelques mots tout à
l'heure de votre parcours mais bonjour à
tous les deux et merci d'être avec nous
alors aujourd'hui avec fred et valentine
il s'agira de parler de la façon dont on
peut réaliser une vidéo de sciences sur
internet pour mettre la vidéo au service
de la médiation scientifique
alors bien sûr on parlera de youtube de
dailymotion et toutes ces plateformes
qui bouscule un petit peu les codes et
qui nous incite parfois à réinventer un
nouveau langage et donc c'est tout
l'intérêt d'avoir avec nous à la fois
valentine youtube euse et fred triki
pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
qu'ils auraient passé peut-être les 25
dernières années en hibernation dans
l'espace a été l'animateur star deux
coanimateurs aux animateurs stars 2 on
essaie d'accord donc il y avait je vais
me toi sabine et puis sabine évidemment
de la petite moi aussi il y avait marre
seul mais quitte à ida subit d'ailleurs
la petite boîte toujours très sensible
et du coup maintenant tu es le rédacteur
en chef 2 d'une plateforme vulgarisation
scientifique en ligne donc qui s'appelle
l'esprit sortie oui mais qui reprend un
peu quel dans le prolongement de c'est
pas sorcier
ça s'appelle comme ça oui on aime bien
faire de l'éducatif du pédagogique
autour des sciences
quand on a arrêté la télévision plutôt
quand la télé n'a plus voulu de nous
ranger dire on avait envie de continuer
nous et heureusement qu'internet est là
d'accord c'est super de revenir
on va en parler justement un peu plus en
détail dans les quelques minutes qui
viennent et également pour dire quelques
mots de ton parcours valentine tu es
journaliste scientifique
tu es donc tu as travaillé avec sciences
et avenir notamment
et puis tu vas également entamer
prochainement très prochainement une
collaboration
ici tu es là aussi parce que tu animes
une chaîne youtube qui t'appelle
sciences de comptoir et qu'il ya une
aussi une déclinaison en ligne avec un
blog parce que ça correspond à peu près
à ce que ses fidèles à ton parcours
exactement le blog est antérieure à la
chaîne youtube en fait celle de 2013 et
j'ai commencé la chaîne en 2015
et puis voilà d'accord vient un peu tout
dessus aussi bien des sciences dures que
des sciences - dur de reportages du face
caméra la voie aux petites animations
faudrait que c'est une particularité de
taille de votre chaîne en réalité elle
est pluridisciplinaire alors que
certaines d'entre elles de chaîne
youtube on en parlera tout à l'heure
sont justement avec plusieurs sujets
plusieurs sciences ou au contraire
focalisés sur une thématique spécifique
alors comme d'habitude tous les
mercredis 11 nathan vos questions
nombreuses sur le chat youtube de notre
chaîne fête de la science donc
normalement le chef château juste là le
temps que je rêve de faire sa part de ce
côté là et vous pouvez donc nous poser
les questions par le biais de ce canal
ou aussi par le biais de twitter avec le
hashtag fds live alors pour commencer on
va évoquer les rapports entre youtube la
vidéo en ligne et la télévision
en effet laurent chicoine lors du ce
premier hangouts nous avait dit depuis
la remise de son rapport et à trois ans
il n'y a connu un essor fantastique
c'est vraiment l'avènement des youtuber
donc
voilà peut-être une vigne perche tout
temps du bon pour toi valentine est ce
que tu pourrais nous expliquer en quoi
consiste la chaîne quelle est ta
motivation pour faire ces vidéos en
supposant que personne ne connaît ce que
c'est car youtube heures pour partir
vraiment de la base bon ma motivation
des vidéos passé de faire des vidéos en
fait c'est de passer de l'information
c'est un peu mon côté journaliste l'a
donc si j'aime bien montrer les choses
qui se passent le joue un peu avec les
les codes et la narration et donc c'est
assez chouette de pouvoir
ce qui est bien avec youtube c'est qu'on
a pas besoin de prérequis n'est rien on
prend sa caméra on va s'aimer ou les
paris et puis là on voit directement
vautours des gens d'accord donc ça c'est
à cette motivation profonde passer des
informations exactement voilà mes de ton
activité en elle-même c'est plus que
parler devant une caméra
il ya tout ce qui est en dehors et qui
cite un travail assez colossales chez
pause
oui tout à fait oui à toute la partie iv
géographique on ne voit pas c'est un peu
la face cachée de l'iceberg
et oui c'est énorme il ya des vidéos qui
m'ont pris six mois de biographies
d'autres beaucoup moins mais
effectivement quand on va creuser dans
un sujet c'est qu'ils m'apprécient moi
je repars pas dans ce genre de sujets
tout de suite en fonction effectivement
des équipes ou des chaînes pour l'esprit
sorcier c'est un peu différent
évidemment c'est pas la même quantité de
travail possible si on est tout seul ou
s'il voulait toute une équipe
je sais pas combien vous a donné 14 14
on a beaucoup de jeunes en forme pas mal
de jeunes journalistes qui sortent
d'ailleurs de l'école enfin pas et
diderot aussi une très bonne formation
master 2 de journaliste on les prend en
contrat d'apprentissage
on a forcément quelques journalistes
professionnels quand même pour les
encadrer parce que c'est super beau
c'est avec des jeunes qui soit mais il
faut aussi sans manger beaucoup de temps
encadré et pareil pour tout ce qui est
technicien vidéo montage pour nos jours
on tourne avec le jeune arrière des
jeunes et des moins jeunes qui encadrent
ces 14 personnes mais un esprit sorcier
finalement en plus d'être une plateforme
de vulgarisation c'est presque une école
remplissent un peu de vie de toute façon
il ya un projet d'école derrière ça
puisque quand on a lancé l'esprit
sorciers en 2015 j'étais un peu un
projet à deux têtes
un média donc on a essayé un goûter
pourvu que ça dure donc voilà on a la
mine médias et moi j'avais envie parce
qu'à l'époque de 7,1 sur site des gens
forts même pas mal de jeunes
journalistes
j'avais envie de créer une petite école
raisonnablement de journalistes pour des
jeunes cons pas accès à ce métier là
parce que je fais encore partie de ceux
qui pensent comme journaliste ça
s'apprend sur le terrain comme je ne
pense pas que ce soit nécessaire de
faire jaillir entre les écoles de
journalisme et bac + 6 c'est un métier
rando et mais on doit apprendre sur le
terrain il comprend un certain manque de
réflexe on va en parler puisqu'on parle
d'informations scientifiques
il y avait un projet d'école aussi qu'on
n'a pas pu mettre en place encore pour
le moment je n'ai pas le temps de tout
faire en même temps je pense que ça va
venir
donc oui c'est très très saint pal de
former des jeunes et et notamment des
jeunes qu'on fait de la science et qui
se mène ensuite ils font apprenons que
je construis ta fac en fait des eaux en
fin au journalisme alors qu elle qui
explique selon vous je pose la question
un petit peu d'années et l'autre
qu'est ce qui explique le succès de ce
nouveau métier entre guillemets de
youtube heures de cette nouvelle
activité
qu'est ce qui explique le fait qu' il ya
une telle quantité de jeunes qui veulent
se lancer dans la vidéo qu'est ce qui
explique aussi leur popularité
est-ce que vous avez un peu des éléments
de réponse à nous apporter je pense déjà
il ya quelque chose qui est naturel
c'est comme quand dans les années 80 les
radios libres se sont créées il y en a
qui sont mis à frapper radio youtube
c'est accessible à tous
on va mois avec un iphone ou un
smartphone
voilà on peut faire de la vidéo si vous
intéresse communiquez avec les gens et
c'est gratuit
techniquement c'est pas trop compliqué
donc c'est bien et ça c'est génial parce
que si ouvert à tous donc c'est combien
on en parlait tout à l'heure presque 100
youtuber dans le domaine scientifique
qui existent actuellement avec des
niveaux évidemment différent donc ça on
peut dire que vous l'y c'est bien parce
que c'est la liberté de pouvoir
communiquer des patients et où par
contre ça représente aussi des risques
et des responsabilités
oui parce qu'a fait pas faire n'importe
quoi effectivement je pense que ballan
qui notamment à pas mal réfléchi à cette
question de légitimité parce que tout le
monde peut prendre la caméra le micro
les exprimer donc maintenant il s'agit
aussi de réfléchir qu'est ce qui semble
pertinent de dire et dans la mesure où
tout le monde peut le dire est qu'il ya
une popularité potentiel à la clé c'est
il faut peut-être imaginer des codes des
garde-fous et donc ça fera l'objet
effectivement d'une partie de notre
gueule
aujourd'hui mais disons avant d'aborder
ces sujets j'aimerais aussi réfléchir un
peu aux liens avec vous entre la télé et
au youtube hulu les vidéos qui ce qu'on
parle beaucoup du tube pas que youtube
com plateforme déjà et non par le
vidéaste sommes exactement
oui c'est effectivement sera le sionneau
on sait que la pub en permanence foyer
et google est absolument de choisir les
meilleurs du coup c'est plus possible de
faire des missions d'organisation senti
comme c'est pas sorcier
aujourd'hui à la télé on va s'affoler
ah ouais je peux en dire un mot de
toutes façons c'est sans moi j'ai connu
des moments difficiles à la fin avec la
télévision mais je veux pas revenir
là-dessus ce pas la question j'essaie de
rester le plus objectif possible mais je
constate quand même et je vais
l'entendre constate l émission est
devenue en vingt ans que c'est toujours
en france un peu difficile de défendre
des émissions scientifiques à la télé
alors c'est vrai il faut reconnaître
qu'il ya des chaînes arte et france 5
ils font des très bons documentaires
scientifiques ya pas de problème
du côté du documentaire scientifique qui
a une très bonne qualité là dessus mais
l'émission télé au sens propre du terme
qui permet d'aborder absolument les
sujets et de se tenir au courant de
l'actualité scientifique
moi je vois pas beaucoup alors il ya des
chaînes comme s'ils ont sévi tv qui
existe heureusement mais bas
c'est pas une chaîne j'allais dire
présente sur la tnt déjà donc cible à
tous et c'est dommage donc oui ça manque
un petit peu à la télé mais j'ai j'ai
souvent eu des discussions et des
responsables d'antennes qui a ré comme
pauvres des sciences je ne comprends pas
pourquoi mes torts des sciences choix
qu'on avait réussi à démontrer pendant
quelques temps que les gens venaient est
extrêmement nombreux regarder les
deschiens nombreuses anecdotes de gens
bien qui sont venus vers moi pour me
disant merci
c'est peu et me sentais pas sorcier je
pense que valentine fait parce qu'il ya
une grande génération
c'est ce qu'on nous dit parfois ça fait
plaisir non mais si nous en faisons
notre travail et on s'est fait plaisir
nous y faire son travail c'est important
mais notre but est ton but a
actuellement aussi il est tout en étant
sur youtube c'est bien je suis en
baptisé la curiosité des gens mais ça
aussi d'essayer de créer des vocations
vers la tente de la tuer par la base de
valentine frais de géomètre son but
c'est refaire une sorte de c'est pas
sorcier ou bien c'est créer oui non
c'est plutôt de faire un truc je suis
pas là pour faire du cette association
mais est-ce que ce que tu as dit c'est
sa maison parce que le rôle que ceux
d'hommes l'invitation particulier c'est
là dessus que j'ai fait mon mémoire
c'est soit de transmettre de la
connaissance donc le côté pédagogique là
un peu comme un prof soit au contraire
le côté susciter la curiosité susciter
l'émerveillement ou des vocations donc
un peu les deux approches
mais dans ce que j'ai pu avec lesquels
j'ai pu discuter on est plutôt dans le
côté pédagogique et moi je me situerais
plutôt donc côté pédagogie c'est que du
côté des devises et leur curiosité aussi
mais mon but premier c'est quand même de
faire passer des informations
oui mais en passant des informations qui
va utiliser aussi la curiosité des gens
par exemple moi je veux gagner quelque
chose
désolé et je veux pas trop parler ne
c'est pas sorcier mais quelque chose qui
me ravit pareillement les 20 ans de
c'est pas sorcier c'est qu'on pouvait
traiter de tous les sujets on avait une
grande liberté éditoriale tout
simplement parce que le public
s'intéresse elle a tous les sujets une
et voir l'émission mais il s'est
intéressé à tout ça veut dire qu'on peut
traiter absolument pour les sujets
scientifiques
or aujourd'hui le réflexe de la
télévision bien sûr
quand ils m'ont traité des sciences ça
je sais bien pour l'avoir vécu assez
souvent c'est de dire auxquelles vous
faites une émission mais sur ce thème là
mais son entame la traitez pas de
l'intelligence artificielle ça
n'intéressera personne et puis c'est pas
ben ismaël éventuellement vous ne
traitez pas de ça donc ils sont très
très sélectif et on revient à traiter
bat toujours les mêmes sujets en
prétendant que c'est le centre d'intérêt
du public
alors comment peut-on connaître le
centre d'intérêt public sur le coût pas
la curiosité et l'intérêt de youtube
aujourd'hui c'est justement c'est ça qui
est génial de pouvoir traiter de toutes
les disciplines scientifiques et là et
l'intérêt aussi que je vois et je pense
que la valentine pourra nous en dire
quelques mots
c'est l'aspect d'interactivité possible
qui est rendue possible par ces nouveaux
outils parce que maintenant il ya les
commentaires il ya aussi la possibilité
d'analyser évident d'audience le moment
où la personne personne va décrocher
est ce que tu construis des vidéos aussi
en utilisant ces outils d'analysé ce que
tient compte des retours
ouais je commence à en tenir compte a
effectivement mais je fais des vidéos
très court en fait je me suis amusé à
tester un peu différents formats et
vidéos de la fin quand je dis je en fait
on est trois à la chaîne je serai sésame
on a aussi morgane et humaines qui sont
mes copines de master justement la
chaîne et et elles sont plutôt du côté
conseil éditorial et où on a vraiment
fait des vidéos ensemble toutes les
tranches donc dans l'eau on a fait un
documentaire de 20 minutes
et maintenant je fais plutôt des vidéos
très courtes de 3 minutes et j'ai
remarqué que les gens finissaient par
décrocher au bout d'un certain moment je
sais plus des deux tiers de la vidéo que
la vidéo fasse 20 minutes ou qu'elle en
phase 3 donc ça c'est assez amusant de
voir qu'on s'y sente comme ça donc il
vaut ils vont jusqu'à la moitié de la
vidéo et puis après c'est dit c'est bon
j'en ai eu assez
d'où l'intérêt maintenant de construire
ces vidéos en mettant toute
l'information au début alors la fin
duvet coin qui n'est rien donc c'est un
peu comme les sorties journalistique
être remis dans l'axé du matador
l'information primaire et après tu
développes c'est normal c'est comme ça
qu'on construit normalement les choses
et pour en revenir à ce que tu disais
avant est ce que maintenant le public
qui regarde s est pas sorcier maintenant
enfin la tranche d'âge n'est pas sur
internet maintenant est ce que ce serait
intéressant de nogent de mettre ce genre
d'émission à la télé est ce qu'ils
voudraient pas me les mettre sur un an
tu peux les mettre sur les deux bennes
de toute façon je ne sais pas c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre on peut avoir les deux
il me semble quand même que c'est de la
responsabilité d'une chaîne publique
financée par des deniers publics du
citoyen nous sommes d'ouvrir la
curiosité et titiller la curiosité et
apporter des informations au public
quoique enfin sympa et blanc au passage
on va vous mettre en temps le lien en
lien par an sur le cloud juste à côté de
nous les chaînes évidemment séance de
comptoir je montre un petit peu le
visuel de valentine qui est peut-être un
peu moins célèbre que celui de fred le
visuel de frais de ses épaules
c'est lui en fait le visuel de l'esprit
essentielle alors en lien à l'heure les
lébous mes collègues le font peut-être
en ce moment même dans le chat pour
assister à vos vidéos voir un petit peu
votre travail s'ils ne le connaissent
pas mais comment le monde de la télé
perçoit justement ce mouvement et
l'essor des youtuber tabac je pense
qu'on n'est pas arrivé à regarder d'un
peu haut comme ça un peu haut
c'est un peu comme la télé le cinéma
unis à l'époque je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez on faisait ou du cinéma ou du
thé les faits vous de la télé donc je
pense qu'il ya ça et puis ça en être
complètement parce qu'ils sont ils ont
constaté je discute avec des gens
d'audience sur les grandes chaînes n'y a
pas très longtemps
ils seront du compte quand il avait une
émission qui marche très très bien
sur france 2 on tout dire très bonne
émission de divertissement on va dire
qu'il marchait bien le samedi soir ils
ont quand même un public qui fait
moyenne d'âge 60 en plus de femmes et 60
ans sur cette émission est au départ les
producteurs voulaient surtout pas que
l'émission soit sur youtube parce que
non on est sur les grandes chaînes etc
et enfin qu'ils sont rendu compte quand
il met la même émission sur youtube ils
font beaucoup d'audience et ils ont un
public de 30 ans à 8 ans à l'émission
elle va pour tout le monde puisque dans
cette émission est à la fois de la
rubrique un peu politique asseoir
politique et reçoit un chanteur r soit
compris maintenant mais c'est vrai mais
ça signifie que cette émission sur une
chaîne publique
bah forcément je pense que
ça vient pas du fait que les chaînes
publiques font des programmes pour les
plus vieux
ça vient de mon reflex ou sans doute que
certains d'entre nous se remettre plus
facilement devant la télé côte voix
internet et tu as parfaitement raison
tous les jeunes on les voit bien ils
sont extrêmement sur internet mais pour
autant faut pas oublier la télé non plus
je sais que c'est pas sorcier par
exemple un de diffuser aussi sur gulli
en ce moment le dimanche soir bon c'est
bien parce qu'eux aussi ils publient
c'est une chaîne qui peut être
rassurante aussi pourront pour les
enfants tu mets pas les enfants à vendre
n'importe quel programme
donc c'est pas mal aussi pour les plus
petites voix c'est pas sorcier il ya des
enfants de 7 ans qui regardent où elle
pourra regarder l'esprit sorciers aussi
mais à le regarder je le regardais aussi
à la télé et valentine ou les huiles
youtuber de manière générale est ce que
ils ont justement des années des outils
d'hélène ce qui permet de connaître un
peu leur public cible est ce que
justement la moyenne d'âge de style
élevés n'ont d'autre que non mais si
vous avez des outils d'analysé un peu
plus fin alors il ya les statistiques
qui sont donnés par youtube directement
ouais c'est google analytics est assez
précis on peut réussir vraiment avoir
quelque chose à ces films en est en fait
la lie à une courbe d'audience qui fait
à peu près comme ça et la majorité de
l'audience à entre 28 et 35 ans à peu
près ce qui est relativement pluvieux
que tu es youtuber plus divertissement
il semble qu'il existe des gens plus
jeunes il faudra vérifier ça avec des
vraies sources a pour le coup j'ai
l'impression que le public des vidéos de
vulgarisation sur youtube est
relativement plus âgé que le public des
vidéos un peu de leurs quatre simplement
si vous avez des infos là dessus nous
vous n'oubliez pas de vous pouvez nous
fact choqué en direct avec le hashtag
fdf n'a évidemment et j'ai envie
maintenant de parler justement du nerf
de la guerre
modèle économique de tous ces nouveaux
outils alors d'un côté évidemment les
rédactions quinzaine de personnes avec
l'esprit sorcier puis de con côté
valentine joue tout seul ou avec un taux
deux autres personnes pour faire vivre
ce sens de comptoir malgré un certain
succès j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont
très peu les youtube heures à pouvoir
vivre en vivre de leur travail et on
parle pas de vivre avec
des sacs d'or ainsi sur deux facteurs
simplement pouvoir en vivre décemment
du coup est ce qu'on peut et est ce que
c'est vraiment un métier dans le sens où
est ce qu'on peut en vivre et comment on
fait alors je parle juste pour les
youtuber watanya louis de la chaîne
biologie tout compris qu'il avait fait
une étude dessus et qui en refait une
maintenant donc les résultats seront
bientôt disponibles
on l'a recevra la semaine prochaine lors
de la journée en présentiel conte
organisée au ministère
donc merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et donc du coup elle avait
fait une étude justement sur la
situation professionnelle des vidéastes
et on voit que effectivement personne
n'arrive à envie ou très peu pour la
grande majorité d'entre nous on a un
bilan nul voire négatif
moi j'ai investi plus de 3000 euros dans
mon matériel et j'ai aucune rentrée donc
voila mais après de mon point de vue je
comprends il y en a beaucoup qui
aimerait en vivre mais effectivement
c'est très difficile sachant que les
sources de financement c'est soit la
monétisation des vidéos sur youtube qui
rapporte extrêmement peu et de moins en
moins chères à mesure que tu veut
modifier sa politique exactement il ya
type ia your type aussi qui rémunère en
échange de regarder des publicités
il ya différents moyens où il ya aussi
le fait d'écrire des livres par exemple
ou de participer à des conférences enfin
ce genre de choses d'animer des
événements mais oui il faut multiplier
le plus possible c'est du coup on a
l'impression que certains youtuber aussi
essayer de capitaliser sur une certaine
u-turn notoriété pour justement pouvoir
faire rentrer des sous par d'autres
aspects du type plus traditionnels type
les d'édition
en écrivant des livres on en connaît un
certain nombre est évidemment et parce
que tout simplement ils ont un public y
est tout acquis puisque ils les suivent
déjà sur la sellette chaîne internet on
peut supposer que les personnes vont
ensuite se précipiter soleil en a
quelques-uns qu'on va essayer a glissé
aussi dans la télé qui forcément au
forcément il ya un peu plus de rides
jeunes parce que bien sûr été libéré en
argent pour produire des émissions
notamment deux rames il a aussi sur
d'accord
donc il y en a quelques-uns d'ailleurs
qui sont d'ailleurs mal mais je pense
rien de très très bons qui sont un peu
dragué si j'ose dire par des chaînes
forcément c'est quand même un vivier de
talents qu'on vient ici pour faire venir
et a tiré peut-être des spectateurs plus
jeunes bonjour notre antenne le cnc qui
a ouvert un fonds j'aimerais voir
combien de vue 50 m c'est à partir de
dix mille abonnés oui là c'est leur
petite étoile est née
je crois donc que déjà casé oui c'est
intéressant d'avoir connaissance et les
institutions que je me désole c'est à
l'un et à l'autre truc que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'il ya des boîtes de
prod qui s'intéresse justement fin qui
vont financer des chaînes youtube
je pense à string theory par exemple
quelle chaîne qui a tenu par la boîte
effervescence je crois et donc ça je
trouve les vitesses sont payés pour
faire leur métier facile vers l or
justement ça nous permet de glisser vers
le sujet suivant qui est le lien avec
les institutions parce que nous même ici
au ministère on a dû travailler avec des
youtuber il ya deux ans que je crois à
l'occasion d'un forum national de la
culture scientifique était organisé à
nantes est d'ailleurs prêt de tués
étaient présents lors de cette soirée
florence porcel qui étaient présentes il
y avait non pas malade mental a si mal
au mental était présent je dis des
bêtises
la chaîne d et éthique etc thomas durand
puis la tronche-en-biais madame jean
louis cohen est pas du coup tout va
durant de la tronche en biais
je vais en oublier donc je vais
m'arrêter là l'énumération sadorge re du
coup effectivement il ya eu peut-être
goudé par une sorte de gens se
regardaient de renifler un petit veut
désormais comment on va travailler avec
le des grosses institutions comme ça et
là et réciproquement les institutions
système et comment on va travailler des
électrons libres un peu incontrôlable et
j'ai l'impression qu'après ça a évolué
quand même assez rapidement une petite
preuve au passage max lord par exemple
est en lien maintenant avec
universcience.tv malade mental justement
à une récréation
à la retombée à saint-etienne donc j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une espèce de ça
évolue et que les tout ce petit monde
s'apprivoise petit à petit j'ai joué un
peu avoir votre sentiment à ce sujet
attendu vous posez d'esprit senti que
j'avais les crocs justement à ce propos
il ya la mystique il a commencé une
réflexion avec le café des sciences pour
voir comment tisser des liens justement
entre les six et sti et les vidéastes et
les vulgarisateurs en général les cafés
décembre s'il ya des blogueurs et les
podcasteurs les pleins de gens très bien
des illustrateurs aussi et ils sont
enfin les autres trouvé plein de pistes
pouvant être développées oui c'est en
train de se faire donc c'est une partie
de la solution peut-être que pour gagner
sa vie grâce à son travail des vidéastes
de faire un pas des institutions et les
institutions fassent un pas vers les
vidéastes oui que je pense qu'il ya eu
un temps d'observation parce que c'est
quand même assez nouveau chagrin de
charette à 10 en 2008 les premiers
youtuber le tous les bus - et donc il y
avait un temps d'observation et puis
aussi de connaître mieux connaître les
gens voir si ce qu'ils font est crédible
je suis à ce qu'une institution qui va
avec un youtube heures quand même il
faut pas se planter
il faut quand même avoir la certitude de
de la qualité la bonne tenue de la
vérification des informations directes
donc voila mais c'est bien c'est bien
que ça se fasse en plus en général ce
sont des gens qui sont à l'aise derrière
la caméra wi qui peuvent être pas mal à
l'aise sur scène aussi
donc s'ils peuvent se déplaçait aller
dans les centres depuis
scientifiques et techniques rencontrés
du public voit il monte et pourquoi pas
des spectacles de sciences génial ça
c'est bien mais c'est autant des
mystères de la science qui sont bientôt
donc
voilà donc tout n'est pas parfait parce
qu'il faut vraiment faire attention à ce
qu'on raconte encore une fois on a une
responsabilité quand on fait ça bien
mais c'est vraiment très très bien que
c'était cette époque et pour l'esprit
sorcier je crois que vous travaillez
très régulièrement avec des institutions
oui bah non c'est notre façon de tourner
parce que tout à l'heure vous disiez les
gens se disent peut-être des comment ils
font pour entretenir quatre personnes on
est un peu particulier c'est vrai qu'on
vient du monde de la télé on a pu se
lancer grâce à des soutiens publics
d'ailleurs d'un routier de l'est
vraiment défendu pour monter le site du
conseil régional d'ile-de-france et puis
à prendre un lancer franc les contenus
une opération de financement
participatif sur kiss kiss bang bang qui
a bien marché qui nous a permis de faire
les premiers contenus parce que les
aides que j'avais eue c'était
d'investissement s'était pas de
fonctionnement et ensuite notre mode de
fonctionnement nous c'est de faire notre
métier de journaliste et de réalisateurs
de programmes éducatifs c'est à dire
qu'on est tous fait de la production et
donc on a une économie un peu hybride
entre d'une part on fait des émissions
pour sion série tv
on a des partenariats avec des
organismes de recherche pour produire
notamment le serrage les sites parce que
c'était le premier qu'on avait mais a
aussi avec beaucoup d'autres organismes
de recherche pour reproduire des
ressources éducatives dont ils ont
besoin
on a une grande liberté éditoriale de
toute façon avec eux notre objectif est
le même c'est d'expliquer comment
marchent les choses donc voilà on y est
ils ont tout à gagner puisqu'ils se
servent
je pense qu'un de notre savoir-faire
pour fabriquer sa ont travaillé les
centres de culture scientifique et
technique plus ou moins gros on s'adapte
forcément au budget de chacun voilà donc
on produit aux produits au premier round
et des producteurs et en a de l'argent
grâce à la production donne les droits à
ceux qui nous aident à produire bien
évidemment comme ça ils peuvent le
diffuser et on arrive à faire tourner la
machine comme ça et on continue à faire
notre métier alors beaucoup ainsi que de
télévision un peu d'internet et des
événements on adore créer des événements
aussi nous montrent la fête de la
science et à la fin de l'océan bientôt
avec
l'aquarium de la porte dorée à paris
enfin voilà lancé dd des événements
comme ça ou pas rencontrer les gens et
par les patients alors on a plein de
questions justement parlez des
institutions on va prendre une question
de l'institution de sa fait le cnrs
images images puis cnrs on salue au
passage le cnrs images nous pose la
question connaissez-vous la fédération
nationale des jeunes youtuber france
non ça commence comme une blague voilà
c'est bien parce que ça permet de
répondre ça existe je sais pas c'était
un test peut-être je n'avais pas du tout
je sais qu'il ya des pourparlers pour
constituer un syndicat des vidéastes
mais j'en sais pas plus si vous avez des
infos comprend d'accord alors une
question qui reste un petit peu dans la
tonalité de nos échanges
delphine gandini nous pose à combien se
chiffrent la collaboration entre un
youtube heures et un établissement de
recherche ou un ccsti par exemple pour
un événement ponctuel
on tourne autour du million d'euros tu
sais les youtube
non mais ça dépend c'est vraiment au cas
par cas ça des membres ça dépend de ce
qui est demandé personnellement j'ai
jamais fait ça donc je serai pas trop
vite
mais si on tourne autour de 500 euros la
vidéo à peu près enfin disons que c'est
le tarif de base à partir de là pour
voir une vidéo à une pour faire une
vidéo
enfin une vidéo ou une institution pour
la ccst mais après je ne saurais pas
vous dire en règle générale ça va
dépendre aussi la notoriété ça va
dépendre du travail demandé c'est
difficile sans doute de pose de répondre
500 euros un million parce que ça va
dépendre évidemment de des cas de figure
mais en tout cas la question mérite
d'être posée sur rome sur la légitimité
des vidéastes on peut concevoir
effectivement tout fait de s'adosser à
une institution ça peut éventuellement
donner un peu d'eux encore renforcer le
crédit de cette parole qui ne
représentent qu'elles-mêmes départ mais
si en plus il ya un partenaire
avec une institution de recherche a
l'impression que ça renforce cette
légitimité
bah oui quand la tumeur c'est enfin ça
donne une crédibilité n'existe que parce
que c'est vrai que si on s'arrête à la
vision de la télé des youtube heure par
exemple
ouais mais alors du coup est ce que
enfin on nous posait une question la
dalle chine gandini surnom c'était le
cnrs images sur une fédération des
jeunes youtuber mais il existe quand
même on peut en parler à ce stade il
existe une fédération plus tôt une
association qui s'appelle le café des
sciences
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que c'est que le café
des halles du café des sciences bien je
suis vraiment désolé qu'il regarde voilà
ce qui fait le café c'est une
association à but non lucratif de
vulgarisateur scientifique en général
ceux dont je parlais tout à l'heure il
ya des blogueurs des podcasts heures des
vidéastes et des illustrateurs des gens
qui font des événements des associations
fallait un peu de tout je crois que
l'esprit essentielle
et voilà nous qu'on s'est réuni et
justement c'est on peut discuter de ce
genre de choses mais là on va de notre
crédibilité dont met en place justement
des garde-fous pour pour pas à dire
n'importe quoi dans nos vidéos fins et
des dispositifs qui sont facultatifs
mais qui sont mis à la disposition tous
par exemple ya des groupes de peer
review sur le principe des publications
scientifiques donc quelqu'un peut
arriver mettre son script de vidéos
d'articles de blogs dessus et il ya des
experts qui peuvent dire oui bah ça
peut-être qu'il vaut mieux dire
autrement ou enfin iiii factcheck en
fait mais quand donc c'est une sorte de
revue par les pairs en quelque sorte de
vérification par les pairs comme ce qui
existe dans les systèmes de recherche
pour garantir le sérieux senti que des
ce qui est affirmé dans les vidéos
regardées un solide bagage
quand même non non pas du tout mais pas
besoin d'un coup de main c'est à dire
que ça permette d'être aidée aussi
oui ça s'adresse à moi je trouve qu'il
ya quelque chose que j'ai découvert en
venant du monde de la télé c'est en live
d'internet
quelque chose qui est vraiment sympa ça
ressemble au café des sciences
ces colis
je sens plus une solidarité j'espère que
ça va continuer et que c'est le cas que
j'ai pu en rencontrer les clients vous
faut pas mentir qu on aime bien sûr des
croche-pieds pas mal est là il ya une
solidarité j'ai pas trouvé
sauf peut-être quelques exceptions mais
qu'importe de mauvais esprit entre les
gens il ya plutôt de l'entr'aide une
complémentarité
donc ça c'est bien dans ce que pour ceux
que ça intéresserait de se lancer sur
youtube ou pour les organismes ou les
les centres de culture scientifique qui
diraient pourquoi pas y aller je pense
qu'ils peuvent s'appuyer aussi sur ce
genre de structure pour avoir des
conseils pour avoir un coup de main ben
voilà il ya une solidarité qui est
propre à internet pour le moment et ça
c'est plutôt agréable
on sent pas isolé alors viens tu viens
de bénévoles beaucoup on est tous amis
il n'y a pas de référence donc le café
des sciences on a bien retenu pour une
sorte de fédération des youtube heures
des blogueurs des utilisateurs en plus
mais un certain nombre de critères de
services en ti de qualité du français je
crois alors je les avais lister les
références sont cités ou pas voilà
d'ailleurs même que lors d'un récent
colloque au cnam
alors qu'il n'avait fait une
intervention et un papier du cou qui est
téléchargeable
on va mettre le lien d'ailleurs juste à
côté ou bien sur ton blog il est
accessible
est ce que tu peux dire peut-être
quelques mots à ce sujet sur cette
légitimité est nouveau et sur les
critères qui sont exigés par café des
sciences pour dix ans un des roms
permettre aux différents youtuber de
monter ou pas dans les rankings de café
des sciences baja est mis de côté mon
compte ben justement d'accord alors
effectivement les critères sont
disponibles si vous allez sur le site du
café des sciences dans nous rejoindre
critères de votre comme ça et je sais
pas si on pouvait trouver ici et donc
tous les critères sont disponibles et
dedans effectivement il ya le sérieux
scientifique qui arrive en première
position
il y aller l'indication des sources le
avoir une posture de remise en question
aussi donc ça c'est très important de
6,6 ont fait remarquer à quelqu'un que à
cet endroit là je suis sûr de ce que tu
écris
c'est bien de regarder la réaction des
gens marchent scientifique ça oui tout à
fait à billes en a qui sont mères
d'adultes en question donnent à l'esprit
du catch s'acquiter intéressant parce
que justement si on à bds qui n'est pas
capable de lui même
bon de toute façon il ya quelque chose
qui est très nette avec internet
je comprends qu'à la télévision c'est le
retour on l'a immédiatement oui donc ne
pas se remettre en question car il ya
quand même beaucoup de personnes qui
doutent il ya tout le temps des gens qui
doutent il ya des mauvais esprits aussi
on sait aussi très bien sur internet y
en a beaucoup
shocking commenté bon vin ça va nous on
est plutôt on a plutôt des bons
commentaires mais elle sur internet on
sait très bien que ça fait vraiment vg
ce prix là pour payer tout ça existe
aussi mais non sérieusement s'il ya des
gens qui jouent dès qu'il disait et qui
vous met des références pour dire vous
avez dit saito immédiatement faut se
remettre en question elle est vérifiée
par ce qu'on peut faire des erreurs
je complète mais on essaye de ne pas en
faire est de travailler en amont pour
pas d'en faire sa mère on peut en faire
mais sur internet on à leur poids est
immédiat ouais mme d'où l'intérêt aussi
décès ou vers les commentaires alors on
a plein de questions à poser évidemment
après des valentins et vous aussi vous
en avez plein donc on va en prendre un
certain nombre puisque l'heure est venue
de d'interagir avec vous chers
internautes alors morgan petit klein
morgan / comme ci comme ça qui nous suit
comment peut-on de susciter des débats
des échanges et des discussions à
travers la vidéo
donc c'est à la première question de
morgane suscité l'interactivité
finalement sur la course en général
donc c'est pas répondre il faut flatter
la question wentz morgan pas encore
réfléchi c'est morgan qui m'a toujours
comme ça doit-on garder le format de
vulgarisation scientifique ainsi un
sachant qui transmet des connaissances
et des non sachant quelle place pour les
expériences et vécu des publics alors
remettre ça se recoupent et moi tout ça
me donne une idée assez rare profitez-en
il n'y a pas vraiment un format du livre
c'est vrai qu'il ya le le truc un peu
standard de fass cam quelqu'un qui parle
à quelqu'un d'autre
mais d'abord il ya plein de formats
différents je vous ai préparé une petite
playlist monde en parlera après d'accord
je sais pas si vous voulez partager
maintenant dans le chat ou pas mais donc
ça c'est pour les formats ya plein de
trucs différents guides et surtout il ya
des certains un vidéaste qui ont pas mal
exploité le côté interactif et qui en
contraire pose une question on va
prendre l'exemple de docteur ousmane
avec ses vrais ou faux
il pose une question à son auditoire
en gros il dit racontez moi ce que vous
voulez sur les moustiques et n'ont qu'à
ce moment là les gens donnent pas des
phrases au hasard sur les moustiques et
après lui valait démonté en disant ça
c'est une idée reçue ça c'est vrai ça
avec des sources à chaque fois donc ça
c'est un un exemple de faim va vraiment
interactif ya plein d'exemples
par exemple ils allaient au gras c'est
dans son format sur la chaîne dirty
biology sur son format comptes relève
qui pose une question n'en sait pas
contre la vie c'est l'expérience qui
pose une question comme comment déplacer
la planète par exemple et à ce moment là
ce sont les gens dans les commentaires
qui vont proposer des solutions et lui
après il en fait la compilation disant
ça ce serait faisable c'est donc en fait
c'est le le public qui fait ses vidéos
et l'aspect participatif loi est
vraiment là exploite les nouveaux
formats du du web ce qui est le plus
compliqué il me semble à la télévision
youtube qui cette fois que maintenant
avec l'avènement de twitter oui s'agite
un peu d'interactivité
ouais j'en fasse chèques les deux
chiffres donnés notamment lors des
débats politiques et ouais d'accord
alors une autre une autre question de
alors des sibeam je crois auriez vous
des conseils pour le référencement d'une
chaîne youtube à faire ou à pas faire
des bonnes astuces et 12 en compte les
sous titres par exemple sont ils pris en
compte pour le référencement
et oui parce qu'en fait c'est là où on
touche vraiment à ce qu'il ya sous le
capot de ses plates formes de vidéos
ce comité qui sont référencés les vidéos
et comment grimper dans la vidéo la
première vidéo qui est suggéré ça je m'y
connais pas assez pour vous dire mais en
gros ses réflexes tradis
neil de référencement et de la cible m
les mots clés les plus importants de
faire un titre accrocheur raccrocheurs
faut faire attention parce que le fx
qu'on n'a pas exemple en presse d'avoir
été d'un accrocheur mais les t2
raccrocheurs il correspond pas forcément
aux raisonnements des gens qui vont à
lui sur un moteur de recherche donc ce
qu'il dit l'école qu'en bas voire le
titre super drôle et tout mais qu'ils
n'évoquent pas complètement les volcans
a plutôt intérêt à dire le volcan
comment ça marche parce que c'est ap les
gens en fait elle moi ça casse un peu
mal la création d'ailleurs de titre mais
bien parce que ça me dérangeait vers un
référencement faire un titre trop
accrocheur type j'ai pas le mystère des
volcans le secret enfin révélé on peut
aussi tomber dans l'excès inverse c'est
à dire peut-être le titre qui est trop
racoleur
oui merci ça peut être drôle parce que
si vous faites un titre comme ça mais si
vous faites un titre comme ça vous
pouvez atterrir dans les playlists de
gens qui regardent des trucs un peu
c'est aux scientifiques illuminati tout
ça peut être intéressant documentaire
que j'avais fait avec mon amie morgane
justement c'est un truc sur une
introduction à la zététique aucun esprit
critique et on avait fait un titre un
peu justement c'était quand notre esprit
nous joue des tours et on a fini sur des
pianistes de gens qui croient aux
illuminati des trucs comme ça donc c'est
tout gagner pour nous alors après pour
gérer youtube il ya plein de technique
du budget d'alors et ça marche je suis
souvenu sur le capot c'est un peu
technique en moi je peins spécialistes
sont occupés chez nous mais il ya plein
de technique par exemple autre jour on
s'est rendu compte
une de nos vidéos a énormément grimper
pourquoi parce que sans doute qu'à ce
moment là il ya des techniques qu'il y a
un outil de comparaison sur youtube où
il voit la vidéo de la même longueur
à un moment donné et quand on passe à
certains cas par exemple et 10000 il
vaut mieux vous référencer et mieux ils
vont vous faire remonter donc des choses
comme ça c'est un peu mystérieux et ça
change assez souvent et sa dombeya
détecter qu'à connaître
64e puis sont peut-être pas très très
très compliqué mais
robin et vous pouvez être nuage et ans
et j'ai l'impression quand même que ces
combines n'aura finalement c'est que de
l'ordre de l'empirisme qu'on peut faire
que des erreurs et on sait pas vraiment
personne ne s'est clairement comment ça
fonctionne c'est pas afficher et parfois
ces jeux c'est dago rythme et changer
modifier
après les albums ne sont changés je sais
que youtube des gros problèmes ils ont
perdu beaucoup d'annonceurs parce qu'il
ya eu des vidéos trash épouvantable
qu'ils ont été mises à un moment donné
ça n'a pas plu à des annonceurs qui sont
partis du coup dans les algorithmes et
on vous promet un certain nombre de mots
clés et pour éviter par exemple des
propos extrêmes et aux on peut enlever
pourquoi pas le mot terrorisme ou
nazisme les seconds voient les émissions
d'histoire sur le nazisme tout certains
ont perdu d'un seul coup tu es bien un
changement chez chez youtube je sais pas
si tu es là c'est ça j'ai perdu beaucoup
d'audience de ça donc ils font vraiment
quand même si on veut savoir s'en servir
ah oui ça ouais effectivement s'est
empirée qui ne connaît pas les
algorithmes de youtube il faut adapter à
chaque fois il me semble qu aux
dernières nouvelles il faut faire des
vidéos d'au moins 10 minutes pour
pouvoir mettre des plus pauvres enfin je
sais pas après c'est vraiment du
bricolage
effectivement en termes de publicité il
ya des youtuber et de youtube buzz qui
sont très futés très repéré par les
marques pour leur potentiel d'influencé
bien présente
je pense par exemple aux beautés souvent
avec buzz
je n'ai pas de youtube heures
en même temps je reste pas ma vie sur
les suis content de youtube le goûter
mais cela vient des influences elles
deviennent carrément des influences je
penserai géraud promouvoir des marques
dans l'écho des marques s'en sert
justement parce que son plus proche
d'eux donc je suis un vrai problème de
crédibilité d'ailleurs les italiens
aujourd'hui il faudrait que cette
personne là soient obligés d'annoncer
qu'elles font la promotion reste pas un
produit parce que sinon effectivement si
moi je me dis d'un seul coup je vais
croire tout ce que tu dis toi sur ton
site parce que j'ai confiance en toi
mais sinon ça comptait payer pas une
marque qu'on me vendre un produit que
c'est très choquant est ce que ça existe
dans le monde et youtuber scientifique
le justement le fait d'être rémunéré
pour le placement produit
oui oui à ce genre de choses mais c'est
très clairement indiquer les fins des
joueurs je sais que les eaux grasses et
avait parlé à un moment d'une émission
sur arte mais lui il a fait ça très
éthique éthiquement jamais mention
d'aidé et donc en fait il en faisait la
pub à la toute fin de sa vidéo c'est
possible je vois chez les youtuber
anglophones c'est relativement courant
de faire ça de faire un truc au début
cette vidéo est sponsorisé par audible
ça n'influe pas sur le contenu éditorial
de la vidéo c'est très important et il
faut que ce soit clairement joué ici par
le web
le chiot empressé de mentionner un
partenariat ou une autre chaîne
hertzienne est puissant et une autre de
vente et de le vendre un produit non
s'annonçait difficile à fait d'accord
quoique non vraiment je connais des
émissions télé qui à un moment donné se
sont pas privés
alors est-ce qu'on a d'autres
d'autres questions qui nous sont arrivés
entre temps je cherche dans les
différents post-it mêlant ddb sibeam
comment obtenir ses premiers abonnés a
si bien vu une victime on n'avait pas vu
ça de l'ap
comment obtenir ses premiers abonnés et
quelques conseils pour lancer une chaîne
alors comment tu as fait pour obtenir
téléphone des abonnés non mais nous on
avait un petit passif on avait 20 ans
quand même des dryades l'émission délais
quand l'édition de cette année il ya eu
énormément d'une pétition des pétitions
des milliers de personnes donc c'est
vrai que ça nous a aidés puis on a fait
du financement participatif avec rodez
par ce financement elle était très
important on remercie vraiment les gens
qui nous ont aidés pour vous permettre
de l'ancien notamment plus contenu
éditorial mais aussi ses moments de
faire de la pub à son rejet retrouver
les quatre mille donateurs qui sont
devenus nos quatre mille premiers
abonnés d'accord pas si donc on en fait
commencé qu'il ne recommencerait tout
moi j'ai une chance incroyable c'est que
j'étais déjà blogueurs dans des tubes
enfin je veux dire vidéaste parce que
sinon mes amis donc du coup j'avais une
petite audience à la base et surtout
j'étais déjà au café des sciences et ce
qui est très bien c'est que quand ce qui
est juste incroyable c'est que les
autres gens du café des sciences qui
sont mes amis ont fait la pub de mes
vidéos aussi ils les ont partagés eux et
beaucoup ça m'a fait plein d'abonnés et
je crois que mes premiers abonnés c'est
mes amis du café des sciences d'accord
et donc oui je comme premier conseil je
dirais pas faire des contenus de qualité
qui quand on est content de ce qu'on a
fait ne pas hésiter à envoyer des petits
messages
enfin appoke et sur twitter des gens un
peu pas très connu non plus c'est bien
de viser des intermédiaires comme ça ils
ont ce que j'ai très connu à mon avis
d'en avoir marre d'avoir des messages
tout le temps ça et puis rejoindre des
collectifs aussi j'ai parlé du café des
sciences mais il ya eu des eaux aussi
qu'un collectif de petits vidéaste qui
va s'entraider justement donc c'est
chouette parce que sa vie il participe
aussi à des événements donc ça permette
d'y participer aussi il ya pas mal
d'événements en france un oeil au
festival ouais d'accord de vidéastes ou
non il ya le festival d historique il ya
bien sûr à nice est content de vous
avoir fait mon mea zeller dessin pas en
avant en premier c'est bien georges lyon
sciences qui est pas uniquement très
bien d'accord il a un concours de vidéos
d'ailleurs c'est très créatif comme on
est au milieu de ce que je l'espère une
note en tout cas dans sa lancée que
finalement il ya tout un écosystème
aussi à maîtriser on est à dire qu'il
faut pas être uniquement vidéaste il
faut aussi savoir nous servir tous les
autres sujets qu'on a parlé dans le bon
camp évoqué dans les précédents ring a
d'ailleurs failli complètement être
carrément et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose que tu as comme
journaliste je pense aussi à ça quand
même non jo les réseaux sociaux bah non
je vais dire oui si les gens qui me
regardent
c'est léger c'est quelque chose qui n'a
pas fait par exemple c'est vraiment
quelque chose c'est fonctionnel savoir
faire de la vidéo vaut savoir ce qu'on
raconte d'abord vous connecter les du
métier de journaliste en fait faut être
community manager comme on dit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire connaître le
fonctionnement des réseaux
c'est un métier à temps complet mais
déjà évite est complètement polyvalent
parce que écrit le script tourner on
s'occupe du son ce que du village sont
aussi la lumière l'étalonnage enfin tous
ces faits là comme près we do c'est ce
qui explique aussi la petite affiche qui
est derrière fred qui avec le monsieur
plein de téléphone c'est un peu l'image
justement le multitask heures salle
multi coeurs alors j'ai une question
l'ade un fidèle de l'émission qui
s'appelle astérix 86 on les passe le
bonjour d'ailleurs y at il des
passerelles entre le web et la télé pour
ses vidéos
sinon ça oui il faut mais quand on est
bon je sais que c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que les
chaînes évidemment c'est leur travail de
repérer des talents et il y en a
quelques-uns évidemment qu'ils sont
retrouvés je crois des cadres de man est
sûr c'est qu'il y en a d'autres
d'ailleurs cherché du thé vert par nous
à travailler dans ce sens ce faire ils
ont cassé un peu la frontière outre le
monde internet et le nord de la télé
après on adapte un peu la production la
production est un peu plus fouillé on va
dire en télévision il ya aussi un peu
plus de moyens ou qui veulent avoir un
style télé mais oui bien sûr il ya des
points ce serait heureusement c'est bien
qu'elle ait les boîtes de production qui
vont investir internet justement
et puis du côté anglophone aussi il ya
veritas y sommes donc là youtuber
science américain chez moi qui a fait un
documentaire en plusieurs parties qui a
été diffusé sur arte il me semble que
oui il ya des passerelles
d'accord ça c'est plutôt encourageant et
bonne augure pour les et pour les
chaînes puisque finalement ça m'a
sûrement dans les deux sens alors une
question de jérémy par line mais il me
semble que on ya un petit peu répondu
tout à l'heure mais je sais pas si vous
avez d'autres idées en traitance pour
bien démarrer il faut solliciter un
réseau d'acteurs quelques exemples on a
un petit peu évoqué le sujet déjà tout à
l'heure mais si vous avez un complément
apporté
il ya eu des hauts et des cafés des
sciences des musiques et vidéos sur ces
corps seraient d'accord en musique
le collectif mais diapason après il ya
la vidéothèque d'alexandrie aussi ils
ont un forum oui si vous voulez des
conseils aussi qu'on vous lancer je sais
pas s'il est encore en ligne mais à une
époque la vidéothèque d'alexandrie avait
un forum avec plein de conseils pleins
de choses intéressantes alors sans aller
jusqu'à la vidéothèque d'alexandrie est
ce que vous auriez justement quelques
astuces ou des bonnes pratiques à
connaître on parle souvent de
storytelling
c'est un mot qui est un petit peu la
mode raconter une histoire pour
vulgariser un contenu pour médias
est ce que est ce que vous avez des
conseils pour éditorialisé une chaîne ce
qui est des règles
moi je suis très attaché au contenu je
dis pas la forme le fond et la forme
jeudi à 50 50 mais le contenu déjà il
est essentiel et c'est là que bon
rapidement je passe tellement mal qu'on
en parlait beaucoup plus m
c'est génial l'explosion qu'il ya sur
youtube mais ça peut être aussi un
désastre
avec ce que tout le monde puis aller et
tout le monde peut dire n'importe quoi
et même des grosse grosse grosse grosse
excusez moi l'expression employée ce que
j'ai dû me traduire leurs déprédations
alors parfois involontairement
travailler sérieusement et puis parfois
volontairement pour bat pour manipuler
les gens donc c'est le meilleur comme le
pire
donc faut être très très prudent faudra
voir les actes du jeu pour essayer de
repérer ceux qui font un peu n'importe
quoi donc la première chose le sérieux
du contenu indispensable on vérifie
cette info on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
erreur mais on la corrige en fait et ça
c'est un gros travail et moi c'est ce
qui m'a fait peur parfois quand j'ai vu
l'explosion des youtuber je me suis dit
mais enfin je connais ce métier depuis
les années des années des années je vois
le temps que ça nécessite d'aller
chercher une information de la
comprendre de la vérifier
et ensuite de la vulgariser c'est-à-dire
faire en sorte qu'elle soit accessible à
tous sans pour autant trahir le fond de
cette des limites de cette pensée de ce
mécanisme scientifique
ça prend énormément de temps alors quand
je vois des vidéastes qui sortent une
vidéo par semaine je vais comment quel
plisson
sous sol où ils ont peu comme un iphone
et donc j'ai juste peur parfois
là dessus ça faisait un petit peu pas en
disant j'espère qu'ils ont bien fait le
boulot sérieux donc ça c'est le premier
critère est ensuite donc le contenu
absolument ensuite chacun trouve sa
forme et tout mais du sourire du sourire
et encore du sourire et des blagues
d'humour et de l'humour et et du plaisir
offrir du plaisir aux gens il a presque
été banni à un moment donné d'ailleurs
enchaîne en télévision justement entendu
dire il faut être très très sérieux
parce qu'il se sent que la littérature
la science est au bout doit traiter tout
ça de façon extrêmement sérieuse ah
ouais mais pourquoi pour qui on n'a pas
besoin de s'amuser avec
alors évidemment faut faire du mot en
fait totalement éloigné du sujet mais
c'est essentiel de donner plaisir aux
gens nous notre travail c'est d'essayer
de vous apporter des informations
fiables et donnait aussi du plaisir
c'est pour ça que la forme elle est
fondamentale mais ça aussi ça prend du
temps c'est un boulot terrible c'est
énorme
donc c'est compliqué hein
il ya des sujets vaut mieux rester
discret et en retrait c'est évident mais
sinon c'était un petit peu allez c'est
pas du mot et puis le mot bah oui faut
bien réussir à faire un serbe étiez
alors disons que la bonne humeur la
bonne humeur apporter de la bonne humeur
et et prendre plaisir à découvrir des
choses je crois que ça c'est fondamental
et puis sur la détester un peu bateau
mais vraiment bien définir sa ligne
éditoriale au début personnellement
c'est ce qui me manque sur ma chaîne
mais gt5 des généralistes quoi oui mais
il ya ça gêne et pour avoir les bras
pendant une signature est effectivement
à adopter un ton on peut faire des cc
après mais après quand on est fixé on
peut avoir plusieurs formats mais
adopter un ton une ligne éditoriale que
les gens s'y retrouvent
par exemple une chaîne que je peux
vraiment bien pour ça c est de sciences
c'est la chaîne du sénat on aura
également comme invité la semaine
prochaine grèce allait avec
ben ouais ouais il a shoe la ligne
éditoriale est vraiment bien défini ils
prennent des images de sciences et il
les explique
oui ça c'est bien il ya à peu près le
même format chaque fois cette vidéo très
courte
sur le même ton présenté par la même
personne que je savais et voilà moi je
trouve ça vraiment bien c'est bien pensé
pour le court et et moi je trouve ça
chouette
après pour les formats du coup si vous
l'avez pas partagé j'avais fait une
petite playlist
c'est le moment de la mettre sur des
formats différents formats qui sont
possible de faire il n'y a pas que le
face caméra sinon pleins pleins d'autres
aussi on peut faire de la mort sur des
images des images un peu des plans de
coupe ou alors sur du des animations de
dessins animés il ya plein plein de
formes a dit chacun peut s'exprimer en
sélection aussi de ce qu'il aime le
dessin ça marche très très bien aussi en
marche bien illustration il traîne un
illustrateur scientifiques aussi alors
je crois qu'il faut chercher son fils sa
patte son ton ouais mais mais mais c'est
bien parce qu'en même temps c'est un
lieu de création où on vous prie pas
alors ok on compare encore youtube et la
télévision c'est normal quand même dans
tous les cas d'essayer de faire quelque
chose entre guillemets de professionnels
et bien travailler et tout mais vous
n'êtes pas primer sur du tout comme vous
mais à la télévision parce que la
télévision on peut vraiment vous serrez
vous changez votre ski et les buts hors
complément qui rejoint d'ailleurs un
propos qui étaient énoncées par laurent
ji quan ho sur le fait que les youtuber
sont des auteurs avancent bien sur wii
et donc ils vont massacrer leur temps et
dans une boîte qui est donc mis en avant
à travers une ligne éditoriale d'où
l'intérêt effectivement dada mettre
clairement en avant alors on va prendre
les dernières questions pour pour
terminer notre émission de jour il ya ce
que je peux être avant très petit cube
j'ai travaillé le land art et pour une
agence de communication qui s'appelle
communiqué et on a monté ensemble le
service vidéo donc si jamais vous êtes
une institution quoi et que vous voulez
vous lancer sur youtube où vous voulez
faire venir des vidéastes ou faire des
trucs avec eux n'hésitez pas à aller sur
le site de xbox et la communication
je vous ai filé lyon
et voilà donc cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par big bang
ce n'est pas vrai c'est une c'est une
blague évidemment il nous reste 5
minutes me dit romain hors change et
donc les boucs que tu essaies de la
casemate
il en sera question dans quinze jours
avec marion sabourdy et pascal moutet
qui seront cette fois ci en direct de la
casemate donc le petit stagiaire du
ministère clément dufresne c'est la
question fut rien et vous que tu vas
essaye justement est-ce que c'est un
format explorer activement ces
séduisants comme format alors première
question on va les prendre en boucle
comme ça ça nous permettra d'y répondre
un peu simultanément et gagner un peu de
temps auriez vous des exemples de chaîne
youtube qui n'ont pas marché
et pourquoi les erreurs typique à éviter
sur une question sur les boucles tube sg
pas d'exemple je sois ghana qui décolle
pas mais après il ya plein de raisons
pour la qualité comme pas peut-être
qu'il ya des gens qui ont elles tant que
telle et chercheurs maintenant de le
faire défiler toute façon je trompe pas
un ya contenu qui est important les gens
peuvent être pacifiée méfiance mais
qu'on le veuille ou non pas y ait des
gens qui passent bien il ya des gens qui
ont pas de moins de style vous
représentez deschamps c'est tout donc
pour quand même ça ça prend un c'est un
métier juste la voit sur des images pose
un problème aussi de voir des images sur
internet
donc dès ce soir mais qui marchent pas
ou il y en a qui décolle pas sans doute
gead exemple pourtant je citerai est
déjà si vous êtes une femme c'est
difficile non
non mais bien d'améliorer non mais c'est
que c'est sérieux soin du visage et près
certain que ça manque d'égards mais il
revient du matin je savais qu'ils en
étaient en dialogue
un moment justement y parer une
opération mais qui nous disait qu'il y
avait moins de youtube buzz
oui on domaine des sciences notamment
parce que se prenaient des commentaires
selon serge et un tas d'autres amas sur
la tombe et fils
j'ai entendu ça me gêne j'aimerais mais
absolument mais enfin il ya une sorte de
discrimination alors une certaine
violence sous couvert d'anonymat il
balance des trucs cool donc c'est une
des raisons que je n'en ai pas le choix
sinon dans les serveurs pas commettre
je pense que la fréquence de publication
c'est vraiment important aussi
ouais régulier quand vous avez un bébé
il faut lui parler régulièrement
fidélisation d'audience faut les
avancées aussi tout faux lui annoncer ce
que vous allez faire une stratégie on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est un métier à
temps complet ça bien définir sa ligne
éditoriale aussi qu'on peut qu'inciter
finalement les jeunes femmes à se lancer
dans la vidéo sur youtube il ya une
dernière question à laquelle on n'aura
pas le temps de répondre probablement
c'était biou comment pouvez vous
expliquer que l'étude gary thater hommes
et plus de succès que les fans par
exemple florence porcel n'a jamais
atteint un chiffre aussi important un
chiffre important d'aborder je suis pas
convaincu domenech je sais pas quand je
suis pas convaincu que je suis ça
voudrait coûte vérifier il ya un gros
précis poser dans la question mais on va
vérifier du coup c'est l'intérêt du fact
checking pasqua je comprends la question
dans le sang soit florence est l'une des
premiers vidéastes comme les femmes
mélangés sur youtube et c'est vrai que
comparativement à d'autres vidéaste qui
sont récents mais c'est vrai que là
c'est non je ne saurais pas expliquer ça
y'a des gens qui se penche sur la
question soit a su lier aux cibles je
sais pas à la matière parce que ce
serait intéressant chez youtube heures
scientifiques bien souvent voilà j'ai
parlé chez claude suréna beaucoup quand
on fait évidemment des études de
sciences pas forcément après de
communication et tous mes dossiers ils
sont dans leur discipline parce qu'ils
sont passionnés de leur discipline
donc est-ce que ceux liés à la
discipline je ne sais pas je sais
peut-être aussi qu un effet statistique
parce qu'il ya moins de femmes en
science donc moins de femmes sur youtube
qui parle de science que d'hommes et
faudra bien regarder
florence porcel
il ya moins de femmes scientifiques
donnent scientifique donc peut-être
qu'il ya moins de ces gros suppositions
l'a peut-être qu'il ya moins de femmes
youtuber scientifique que d'hommes
youtuber scientifique et que du coup il
ya un effet statistique qui fait que ben
celle là ils ont moins d'abonnés celle
qu'on regarde en moins d'abonnés que les
hommes mais ya plus d'hommes ne verrez
qu'il n'ya pas besoin d'être un une
femme pour regarder florence porcel des
versements pas besoin d'être un homme
pour regarder ok alors du coup on va
s'arrêter pour eux pour aujourd'hui
parce que malheureusement le temps est
écoulé et nous est imparti est écoulé
quelques annonces pour terminer la
semaine prochaine comme on a mentionné
au cours de l'émission il n'y aura pas
notre traditionnel rendez vous à 13
heures parce que tout simplement on a
une journée en présentiel qui sera
organisée sur le sujet débat 2.0 une
journée organisée au ministère qui nous
permettra autour de tables rondes
d'ateliers de mettre en place une
réflexion autour des réseaux sociaux
dans le cas de la prochaine fête de la
science on est en train de réfléchir et
élaborer une action nationale sur les
réseaux sociaux donc ce sera l'occasion
soit d'être là avec nous soit de vous
rattraper en regardant les épisodes que
vous avez manqué les semaines
précédentes donc on vous donne rendez
vous le 23 mai avec marion sabourdy
parce qu'elle doutait et le dit chérif
qui seront le pardon le trentenaire me
dit le dis en levant les bras au ciel
donc c'est le dit justement qui est le
dit chez vous qui animera cette cet
épisode je vous dis qu'une chose ça va
être super donc soyez au rendez-vous
dernière annonce le forum national de la
culture scientifique technique et
industrielle
il aura lieu le 22 mai c'est mardi
prochain au ministère
donc le sujet ce sera culture
scientifique et europe soyez aussi au
rendez vous et d'ici là n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo avec vos amis et
les professionnels de la culture
scientifique
je vous remercie beaucoup fred et
valentine merci beaucoup
ciao ciao